die stimmung war natürlich angespannt
sie war teilweise sehr aggressiv steine
sind auf polizeibeamte gefallen geworfen
worden
das sind es flogen flaschen und was eben
teilweise auch sehr schlimm war war eben
die sachbeschädigung sind autos
angezündet worden
hier im prenzlauer berg den tesla wagen
haben wir auch gesehen und was eben auch
für viele anwohner ganz schlimmer die
scheiben der geschäfte sind zerstört
worden hier hat man alles was nach etwas
luxus ausgesehen hat 1 geschlagen die
scheiben und wir stehen auch hier vor
einem ballett geschäft der waren ballett
waren verkauft auch hier wurden scheiben
eingeschmissen hier in der alten
schönhauser straße die ganze straße ist
im prinzip verglast worden ist sind
dutzende von geschäften und ich stehe
hier neben der philips das ist der
eigentümer des geschäftes herr philip
wie haben sie das wahrgenommen gestern
die gewaltorgie dass hier alle geschäfte
angegriffen worden sind und am gar nicht
ich habe geschlafen
heute morgen meine angestellten haben
angerufen und gesagt du passt man auch
wir haben probleme und und wie vor sechs
jahren haben die hier sämtliche scheiben
einfach eingeschlagen verstehe nicht
warum es gibt überhaupt keinen sinn weil
wir versuchen alle momentan unsere läden
über wasser zu halten und seine
angestellte aus dem kurzarbeit
rauszubekommen
und dann kommt so eine eine schaden 3
4000 euro pro scheibe so was sind diese
drei es ist einfach verrückt ist einfach
verrückt hätte man das verhindern können
da muss man mit die polizei sprechen die
haben gewiss ganz andere sachen im kopf
gehabt als kollateralschaden gestern
abend aber
keine ahnung wenn das wirklich von diese
lieblich straße 34 ist das verstehe ich
nicht kommen ich würde auch mit
hilfreichen wo das wäre fantastisch aber
man braucht nicht so einen schaden
anzurichten was hat das mit mir zu tun
und diese andere läden
das ergibt keinen sinn da möchte ich
neben mir noch thorsten rau nach
vorstellen heraus sie sind glasermeister
für sie eigentlich in weihnachtsfest
wenn man das zynischerweise sagen darf
aber es ist ja grauenhaft also die ganze
straße runter wenn man das sehen kann
ist zerstört worden
was für ein schaden haben sie bemerkt
was müssen sie jetzt machen also 2013
hat mir das gleiche schon mal auch über
liebig14 damals da war der komplette
straßenzüge auch wie jetzt mit steinen
beworfen worden
und wir hatten auch stunden nur zu
verglasen dadurch dass wir 24 stunden
notdienst einsatz sind das ist uns
natürlich eine leichtigkeit hier vor ort
zu sein und wir werden jetzt sehen was
wir alles notdürftig notfall blasen
können und dann später reparatur
verpressung durchzuführen aber so ist
das erst einmal abgesichert die
unfallgefahr ist gehemmt und wie gesagt
die kolonne ist jetzt im einsatz um mit
wieviel scheiben handelt es sich wie
groß ist der schaden was würden sie
sagen also letztes mal hatten wir
ungefähr 33 schaufenster hier zu
verglasen den jetzigen stand kann ich
noch nicht etwa gleichviel oder was wir
ja denke ich ja auf jeden fall weil um
durch straße um rosenfelder rosenthaler
straße ist ja so kurze antwort letzte
frage wie reagieren hier die anwohner
die durch geschäftsbesitzer das kann man
so etwas nicht verhindern
doch kann man sicherlich das ist eine
politische sache da kann ich mich jetzt
aber hierzu nicht äußern
es sind natürlich immer wieder die
randale
die groß geschrieben wird hier und da
sollte was gegen gemacht werden
dankeschön rauner
das sind so die ersten eindrücke hallt
von den anwohnern die kommen jetzt und
auch die geschäftsinhaber so purple zu
ihren geschäften hin begutachten den
schaden
die meisten sind natürlich versichert
aber wir haben auch mit anderen
geschäften namen angesprochen die eben
nicht vor die kamera möchten aus angst
eben die sagen was hat das mit einer
hausbesetzung zu tun was hat das mit
politik zu tun und immer wieder die
vorwürfe gegen den senat das man soetwas
toleriert dass quasi ein rechtsfreier
raum geschaffen wird durch diese
besetzten häuser und das von den
anwohnern daraus eben auch teilweise
harte straftaten begangen werden dass
man nicht dagegen vorgeht und hier bei
aller demonstrationsfreiheit und bei
aller freiheit generell muss man sich
doch dann fragen eben das machen auch
die geschäftsleute hier hätte der senat
nicht im vorfeld eventuell was machen
können zu dem man auch einen
demonstrationszug durch eine
geschäftsstraße straße leitet auch das
versteht kaum einer
und so werden halt viele viele fragen
jetzt noch zu beantworten sein und biete
eine frage hätte ich auch noch an dich
wie sieht es denn jetzt in den nächsten
tagen aus man darf er jetzt nicht davon
ausgehen dass alles vorbei ist oder
also ich habe vorhin mit der polizei
noch gesprochen und die arbeiten jetzt
erstmal alles auf die haben die nacht
rekapituliert und haben gesagt na ja es
ist relativ ruhig abgelaufen
eine prognose zu wagen ist daher sehr
schwierig zumal man auch nicht so
richtig weiß bei den demonstranten bei
den krawallmachern irgendwie viel
krawall touristen es sich gehandelt hat
das heißt die leute die heute oder
morgen dann eventuell wieder abfahren
aber es ist natürlich nach wie vor
höchste einsatzbereitschaft vorhanden
bei den behörden
sie rechnen natürlich damit das ist
vielleicht noch im zuge von der räumung
von liebig 34 das nach nächtens halt zu
weiteren aktionen kommen könnte das
haben wir gestern gesehen mit dieser
interaktiven karte es kann sein dass da
eben noch kleine gruppen aktiv werden um
dann eben anschläge zu verüben auf
maklerbüros oder eben bei rechtsanwälten
aber demonstrationen sind in der
nächsten zeit nicht geplant
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren